only certain first ladies allow them to
cover a vogue and social media is
selectively banning speech again with a
media blackout edition of seen and
unseen Raymond Arroyo Fox News
contributed New York Times bestselling
author of The Wheel Wilder series in the
book the amulet of power Raymond now why
do we only seem to see one party
represented on the magazine rack want to
talk about First Lady Michelle Obama
well it's pretty much been on it it's
not only first ladies but Vogue editor
Laura and Anna Wintour known for her
severe bob and solar shields sat down
with your favorite journalist Christiane
Amanpour and she explained why certain
political figures of first ladies get
covers and others don't I mean you're
overtly political what is it that you're
trying to say by profiling a Michelle
Obama or a Kamala Harris or even a
stormy Daniels I believe as I think
those of us who work at Conde Nast
believe that you have to stand up for
what you believe in
I don't think you can try and please
everybody all the time please everybody
all the time so with no concern about
alienating viewers or readers winter
went on it is noticeable that there are
more democratic women from the
Democratic Party in your magazine and
profile than there are Republican I
wonder whether there's a reason for that
I think it's very very important to have
a point of view we profile women in the
magazine that we believe in the stand
that they're taking on issues we support
them in in the fact that we feel that
they are leaders Laura there is one
moment it will never appear on the cover
of any one of these magazines do you
know that woman might be Laura Schara
for this one what see it well was the
control room is lost that woman no not
that one no wrong woman Laura
maybe they'll figure it out by the time
we're done these glasses to Mary well
there it is that's the woman hope never
well you got to go on bro
yeah before we leave you ventured
Michelle Obama she has me out three of
these vogue covers and for this reason
Laura novice Leona on a very selfish
note speaking as the editor-in-chief of
Vogue she did wonders for fashion she
loved a fashion you see she's so
different from that dowdy Melania she
has nothing she doesn't know anything
about fashion Lord just jumpers and
smocks with Melania well first of all
the fact that I don't want or must
continue to wear the glasses she says it
so people don't know what she's thinking
oh is that right I think we know what
she's thinking I'm a big liberal and I'm
gonna put all my liberal tripe out and
what are you wearing tonight by the way
where's this Laura big news oh I'm sorry
to interrupt we got to get serious here
I started interrupt there is tonight a
Fox News Alert made a huge announcement
on the Colbert show two nights ago and
it was one of those moments steeped in
history I see a country and quicksand
I'm able to solve problems and threats
from abroad I'm able to make life better
for people here at home I'm ready to
solve these problems I'm running for
president United States well Laura let's
go on there was a there was a big bat
band this week the other day a social
media video appeared with Trump squaring
off with his ideological opponents now
music from The Dark Knight played
beneath the video after the president
retweeted it that's not the Dark Knight
music has supposed to receive 90,000
likes two million people thought it was
taken down from Twitter last night
citing copyright violation I call it the
Batman because Warner Brothers claims
the Isaac was not authorized for you
it's not a campaign but you're getting
ahead of me they claim you cannot use
this music in a campaign video and they
are threatening legal action I take the
white I say bring it again this is
another liberal play you think they
would be gone Obama's you know what's
this well I mean here's a nice tail for
remember this is a person in the
blogosphere who just posted a video it's
they're not a campaign employee so the
fact that we did it does that mean all
the 90,000 Reid tweeters are they all on
the violation Warner Brothers now for
copyright violation I think not can I
borrow those glasses No
they know these are Anna Wintour all
right fine I don't want to know people
to know what I was thinking but by the
accent final agreement did you see where
the National Science Foundation unveiled
well there it is an actual photograph of
a black hole
yeah pretty amazing actually they use
several telescopes now what do you think
when well what when I first saw it I
thought this is what happens when I take
my glasses off at the dentist's office
you know you look up at that circular
light that's how it looks a fuzzy hole
what did you think when you saw it it
looks like the solar eclipse or the
lunar and just but it's it scares me
just to look at it well it's I'm glad to
know there are black holes I want to go
back in time to a time when Anna Wintour
didn't politically decide who was on the
cover of Vogue that would be a nice time
I was like yes so Paul you can get
sucked in and you can go to back in time
parently or whatever matter disappears
I'm all night black hole is like the
Judiciary Committee wanting documents
they're never gonna get them from from
the trumpet that's a black hole